BARTON'S GOT IT.
THE CROWD IS STANDING.
25 SECONDS REMAINING.
TEN ON THE SHOT CLOCK.
MORRIS.
CORNER THREE.
OFF THE MARK.
TEN SECONDS TO GO.
NUGGETS HANGING ON TO A
ONE-POINT LEAD.
WOODS.
GORDON'S GOT IT.
IT IS A BLOCK!
NIKOLA JOKIC BLOCKED THE BALL.
NOT TODAY BUDDY!
THE NUGGETS HAVE THE W!
THE SECOND BEST DEFENSIVE RATING
IN THE NBA THIS SEASON IS NIKOLA
FOLKS.
>> Scott: WE SAID ABOUT THE
FIRST QUARTER GOOD CHALLENGE GET
OUT OF GORDAN'S HAND.
THAT IS PRETTY GOOD.
I WONDERED AT FIRST.
>> Chris M: JAE'SEAN TATE
POINT-BLANK RANGE AND JOKIC GETS
IT OUT OF THERE.
>> Scott: THAT'S A CLEAN BLOCK.
>> Chris M: THE NUGGETS PULL ONE
OUT.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
TRAILING BY FIVE WITH 2:44 TO
GO.
AND AARON GORDON HITS TWO HUGE
THREES.
JOKIC WITH A DEFENSIVE PLAY OF
THE GAME.
THE NUGGETS IMPROVE THEIR RECORD
TO FIVE AND FOUR.
THE HOUSTON ROCKETS GO TO ONE IN
EIGHT.
THE ROCKETS NOW HAVE LOST 13
CONSERVATIVE ROAD GAMES.
ALL RIGHT.
RIGHT NOW LET'S GO TO KYLE
SPELLER.
>> LET'S SEND IT OVER TO KERRY
ANN STANDING BY WITH NUMBER 15
THE JOKER.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOU GUYS COME IN.
FIRST GAME OF A FIVE GAME HOME
STAND.
HOW GOOD DOES IT FEEL TO GET
THAT WIN IN.
>> IT IS A IF YOU HAVE WIN.
IN THE FOURTH QUARTER WE CAME
BACK AND GET THE BIG SHOT.
WE ARE HAPPY TO WIN A GAME.
>> SIX TIMES THIS SEASON YOU
HELD THE OPPONENTS TO UNDER 100
POINTS.
WHAT DOES IT SAY ABOUT YOUR
GUY'S DEFENSE?
>> WE ARE TRYING.
ESPECIALLY AT HOME.
WE ARE TRYING TO BE A TEAM.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO.
>> TAKE US BACK.
WALK US THROUGH THAT BLOCK
THERE.
>> I MEAN, THEY HAD TEN SECONDS
IN THE BLOCK.
THEY WERE ATTACKING.
THEY WERE DOWN ONE.
THEY WERE JUST ATTACKING.
PASS TO GORDON.
I JUST HAPPENED TO BE THERE.
>> FIRST TIME IN A NEW UNIFORM.
IS THAT GOING TO BE LUCKY
SCORING?
>> WHO KNOWS.
I LIKE THOSE.
THEY LOOK GOOD.
>> THEY DO LOOK GOOD.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THAT WAS NIKOLA JOKIC.
>> Chris M: IN HIS CITY EDITION
UNIFORM.
A SPLENDID GAME FOR JOKER.
A COUPLE OF STEALS.
AND THE DEFENSIVE PLAY OF THE
AFTERNOON A GAME SAVER.
YEAH.
JOKIC